there's almost like a new force in the
universe that selection drives
complexification such to the point where
systems can become self-governing
self-referencing and when an object
cares about its own existence in time
it's on the way to life
am i right in thinking that you're in
scotland now
yep i'm in glasgow given the fact that
we might be talking a lot about
adaptation
in this conversation how have you
adapted to
understanding the accents of everybody
that's around you in glasgow did that
take time
i i'm still struggling i think the thing
that i'm getting better at though is
being water repellent
ah
because it's so rainy yes well as
someone that's from the northeast of
england i feel your pain
yeah
yeah it's a it's a strange it's a
strange climate up there
what does
life is the universe developing a memory
mean
i'm not sure i know now it seemed like a
good phrase at the time now um
i think it's the simplest way i can
describe the process by
soulless matter or stuff that's not
directed
is able literally to act on other stuff
by experiencing stuff in stuff now that
sounds a bit weird
but i can unpack that because it's kind
of interesting and that um
um
i think that i realized in the last few
months that there is this transition to
kind of from sand if you like
all the way to cells but actually via
kind of functional objects as you think
of sand on the beach
and the sand has no memory so the wind
is blowing around and you know maybe
water's coming in but maybe every now
and then some clumps of sand maybe let
some clumps of sand get blown together
in a triangle and they become resistant
to weathering from either side and that
triangle is able to kind of remain exist
for time and if that triangle can have a
material effect
on other sand next door and that carries
on you can see maybe how the triangle
could literally make lots of triangles
and so that in a way is like a little
rudimentary memory because the effect of
that
that chance arrangement has a material
influence on the future
and so it's those little bit little
things that occur in the universe able
to then
um remember that by physically building
things i think what i mean
um
as opposed to say um i don't know
you know if you've got a flame and you
burn things you lose
they're all the the the material that
came before is destroyed no longer
exists so it has harder time to have an
influence on the future
and i suppose it's literally meaning
that the past
has an effect on the future because of
the state of the past like you know what
the shape of the object is so that's
really what i mean is that the past
really does have a meaning which is
obvious probably to us but not to
physicists who basically think the past
doesn't exist um i learned about slime
molds a couple of weeks ago and they i'm
aware that we're jumping ahead and we're
getting into something that is
definitely life but they kind of have a
memory thing right they leave uh
hormones or they secrete pheromones and
leave them around and then when they go
back they can know not to go to this
particular place this is a mold
yep
they can train them to go through mazes
and [ __ ]
yeah exactly i mean slime molds are
really good at doing that bacteria are
able to communicate by that so it's all
this kind of this idea this constraints
because the thing about the problem with
life the difference between life and
non-life you know when you've got life
like a slime mold or sand right someone
said here's some sand here's some slime
mold
can you tell the difference most people
would be able to tell the difference but
that's that that jump that you need to
go through to get from sand to slime
mold that people really had trouble with
and i think
um this understanding that the universe
is kind of
life is the process by which the
universe not only
um has memories but starts to initiate
the process of recording those memories
and making them more and more
sophisticated so we're able to go to
abstract them so you the going from sand
to super
intelligence is actually a fairly
obvious thing that should happen in the
universe believe it or not
what is the
most difficult step as far as you can
see
from something which is completely not
alive to something which is maybe as
alive as alive can be
is it the
uh origin of life is it going from
single cell to multicellular organism is
it not destroying yourself with global
warming
where along that spectrum can you see
the biggest great filters oh
i think i can think of three or four
really interesting transitions the way
to put put it and so the first one is
like let's say the first transition is
from the random
to the so the kind of physical world
where statistics rules and particles are
everywhere to
the kind of
chemical world where things a little bit
less random because there's little bits
of memory bonds you know you can have
you can cut diamonds they have faces and
so on so they have features so you go so
that so that distribution narrows
slightly what would be sorry what would
be an example of the first type
um just um
i suppose
uh very basic particles say hydrogen gas
moving around right gravity would tend
to bring it together so you clump
together and you build a star okay
but then when you go to so you've got
this transition from in physics and
chemistry to then biology
biology so let's say physics is just
statistical
mess
but gaussian mess biology is also a mess
but biology is quite good at reproducing
almost the same features so if you had a
twin or you had some identical cells
they'd be different but you could see
that they were the same thing or that or
a couple of cats
so but they wouldn't be like just random
mess there'd be a narrow distribution
you're identifying the cats and then if
you go from cats to the iphone several
iphones you look inside the iphones the
iphones would be pretty much identical
same pcb same um
kind of transistors if they're the same
type so the distribution would narrow
almost to a thin line so you have broad
distribution kind of random one narrower
one for biology and a thin line for
technology so what is really interesting
is that transition from kind of a random
distribution to a less random
distribution for biology which is
evidence of evolution and then evolution
to technology so you're saying what is
the hardest jump
well i think the hardest jump is
basically
um because we don't yet understand
the force if you like that enables to
initiate evolution everyone thinks that
evolution is something that only exists
in life
but if that's the case where did the
life come from and you have this
proverbial
i think it's not impossible to
understand how you go from a single cell
to multi-cell hard but not impossible
not impossible then to go from
multi-cell to animal and then animal
tool making to to consciousness and
stuff but so that first jump from the
sand to the cell the molecular machines
is something we have no handle on
because it occurs in the molecular
regime
and so this is where the chemists need
to be doing their detective work so i
think that we should nail it soon but it
is fascinating that we have no idea what
happened none
that's the k that's the current state
of the origin of life research
is that we have no idea how it happened
i i mean i think i have an idea but
that's because i'm bi you know i'm
biased i'm doing experiments i have an
inkling
i think i feel like i'm the first to a
party like the electricians when people
were renting electricity you had all
these arguments between the voters and
the ampers and people some people
thought electricity was a liquid some
people thought it was you know they
didn't really know because there was
static electricity so people's hair
standing on end there were batteries and
there was this there was this paradigm
where no one knew it was a free-for-all
so
and not ever no one was completely right
and no one was completely wrong there
was a spectrum and i think right now we
have what we call prebiotic chemists who
basically retro go back and just try and
recreate the events
we have biologists who say ah chemistry
is easy let's get to genes and go from
there and then you have um people who
are trying to understand the origin
story to say well
we need to kind of
let go of life on earth as being the
only thing and say what general process
gave rise to life and i'm probably the
first in a new discipline of people that
are willing to say that this is an
answerable question
and in fact i have experiments running
in my lab right now i'm literally just
shaking sand in a box hoping for slime
mold to come out or maybe something a
little bit less scary in the slime mode
right
you're shaking you're shaking sand in a
box
to just see see what happens literally i
mean it's a bit more chemically
sophisticated so probably would have
some water and in that water we'd have
some inorganic minerals some rocks
and those rocks kind of act like you
know the beginnings of if you can etch a
rock and have a little cave in it or or
a chance crack that crack becomes a
place where a memory can be born because
that crack maybe can trap some molecules
and those molecules will be given safe
harbor from the environment so those
molecules can basically react with each
other to make another molecule and then
if these come together you'll keep
building
more and more possibilities to explore
chemical space and then in chemical
space there are some special molecules
called replicators which only occur
very rarely but those molecules are able
literally to fabricate each other
or even better fabricate each other in
in groups so it's almost like imagining
having a you know if you have someone
fabricating a table in a chair
um like carpenter you imagine that the
table fabricates part of the chair and
chair fabricates part of the table and
together the table chair exists as an
entity and that's how the thing
become evolves because it doesn't need
the carpenter they it's a symbiotic
relationship and that's the thing that
we're searching for in the sand shaker
in my lab why would it be
sand
with water
given the fact that life is
carbon based
yeah good point so because um
i mean carbon is just
a useful it's a useful element because
it can make a large number of
um
um strong interactions so the reason why
you know if you think take plastic and
flex it and bend it and so on that
that's all based on based on carbon and
carbon has that property to make what we
call polymers and those polymers are
really versatile
and so on planet earth
the carbon was in the form of methane
and probably carbon dioxide the simplest
forms of carbon and then what happened
there was a load of you know there's um
obviously hot rock coming out from the
center of the earth and there was water
probably and the methane would probably
start to form tar reactive oxygen form
tar sugars
not living sugars just really really
terrible gooey black tar the co2 would
also react
and so these polymerization reactions
would happen but they would happen in
the sand and the sand would act as like
a catalyst or a controller to basically
you know um
direct the outcome of those reactions so
literally my lab is like a load of um
methane carbon dioxide in a load of sand
being heated up it's a kind of a messy
pile of junk and [ __ ] is there a machine
a little automated
machine sifter that's just wiggling
boxes
we can do shaking but we do stirring we
have networks and the way to we have
like basically it looks like a
um a load of different test tubes
so maybe say a rack of test tubes or two
racks but they would be isolated they'd
be connected like a network so we kind
of make the chemical internet so what we
could do is we could transfer the
contents of one test tube to another to
seed all the different test tubes so we
literally take
really spread all the material around
for maximum searching of the chemical
space
so how do you define life what's the
difference between life and not life
um
physically no idea
um because every i in fact i i would say
i mean i'm being facetious in a way but
i think it's really important i think
that
um
i will i will now contradict that and
say of course this is a definition of
life in mata
if you take a let's say if i take a
snapshot of you frozen in time you would
be as dead as a rock right i've seen and
i take the same snapshot i would not be
able to know you're alive
so so it's not just the stuff in you
right uh you know if you shed a tear the
water came from a living eye but the
water doesn't have any emotion it's just
water maybe some salt in it or something
so people get really stuck thinking that
life they have to kind of say life have
these properties of you know you've got
a metabolism you've got all this stuff
and whatever and i think that's far too
hard because you end up having to take a
survey a focus group you know hello
alien can you please for take these
following questions if you say yes to
most of them you'll be alive do you
aspire yes do you do you evolve do you
metabolize yeah
and so
and nasa got its stuff is it's kind of
got really stuck because if you say to
covid19
is cov19 alive it's a virus particle
most people will say no viruses are dead
like well okay good no problem no
pandemic well of course that's incorrect
when a virus particle gets into your
cell it hijacks the cell gets its
nuclear material replicated makes lots
of copies of itself leaves the cell goes
around and can tarry that's its life
cycle
so um
a friend of mine
um who uh
kind of was the last person to touch the
hubble he's this astronaut i try to
convince him of this about light
difference in life so i said there's no
difference between him the astronaut and
the virus particle
except when he's in space he's like a
virus particle he can't have children
when he's you know he's when his oxygen
runs out and everything runs out he's
going to be a dead astronaut he has to
come back to earth and on earth he's
able to breathe have kids or look after
his kids whatever do stuff so the
current notion of life that we have is
not appropriate so now i ask that say
that i ask a different question to is
something to live is to say okay
let me you know take you or an object
and you say right is this
a product of a living system
and then or evolution and i have a way
of
telling
giving you an answer to that question
without um with almost 100 accuracy and
so what i define life as life
is a process
that can build
objects
that cannot form in a random environment
so i'll say that again life is
characterized by the ability to build
stuff
in abundance
that can't form by random chance
so
you can think about dna and proteins and
cells we could also think about this
mouse
this mouse if we go to pc world and buy
10 of these mice it's a microsoft mouse
it's probably okay if you found 10 of
these mice on mars
you wouldn't say oh my god it's a random
rock you'd be like that's weird there's
10 electronic things that look like a
mask i've found back on earth they're
identical this must be proof that life
has been here it might have dumped the
mouse myself and ran away but those
objects they don't need to be alive
themselves but they are read out on life
so i think don't ask if you're alive ask
if you can leave artifacts that prove to
other people who follow your trail that
you were alive when you do that that's
so liberating because then you see flame
isn't alive the spot on jupiter is not
alive
clouds aren't alive but if you found you
know 10 identical clouds in the sky with
lots of features you would know they
weren't clouds that was a evidence of
life in the atmosphere so you're not
saying that the mouse is alive what
you're saying is that something which
seems to present a highly ordered
environment that couldn't come together
by chance is either life or an artifact
that shows that life was there exactly
so that's it this is intrinsically
related to time and entropy in that case
yes
how yes yes why
well you might know that i'm not a
really a lover of entropy or well you
can choose one or the other right you
can choose entropy or choose time
and so what i mean by that is that
because we live in the universe the
physicists think that time does not
exist we have to have this thing called
entropy
and so what that means is that um
in
in any in the universe's entropy is
expanding which is another way of saying
the universe is asymmetric and there's
time so entropy is just this
it's kind of a nons it's actually a kind
of nonsense term and i feel bad for
boltzmann because i'm a chemist i love
setting fire to stuff right and i'm not
saying that the second law of
thermodynamics is a falsehood
i'm saying that the second law of
thermodynamics is a misrepresentation of
how the universe works
so lots of people think the universe is
going to end a heat death i don't think
that's necessarily guaranteed why
because i think the universe is going to
basically end up just keep building
stuff who's
there i think there's a series of
ratchets
and human and humanity's been doing it
technology ratchets and what happens is
that basically we take all the available
energy and resource
and by abstraction we build machines
that can then harness more energy and
regionals more sophistication we go up
and up and up and up and up and up and
up
and i don't think that needs to be a
heat death we can regather those now
that means that actually there's
something very interesting about what we
mean by spontaneous
processes and entropy over time but i'm
not saying that time doesn't exist time
must exist and because time exists the
universe expands and because the
universe expands there's more space over
which you spread stuff out which is what
the second law in entropy says but that
doesn't necessarily say that everything
has to spread out and die
right there needs to be enough resource
to get there but we just don't know
enough about it and i like to poke the
physicists but i don't want to go too
far because um
entropy is a useful
uh measure of it of labeling or if you
look at tooth if you if i give you some
snapshot of a room they say my office
here and i put some neon gas
in my room oh no let's say some radon
gas so i wouldn't want to be here
because i'd be radioactive but i had
some goggles and i could see the
radioactivity and i put in a plume of
radon gas in one corner of the room if
you look like ghostbusters you have
green plume right so what would happen
that would be at t equals zero
what would you predict would happen at t
equals one hour well then the radon gas
would spread out uniformly in the room
and you'd kind of have this green haze
so you were basic when i give you those
two photographs which is the beginning
and which is the end you
would look at it and go oh that's the
beginning in the end you would assign
that you would label it and so the funny
thing about that is that um you have to
be the labeler
but you could somehow take all those
molecules and if you flip all these
molecules back you could push them back
into the corner you would do work on
them and that work would be against the
second law it takes some energy and you
know that that's all kind of accounted
for
so i'm not saying there are perpetual
motion machines but i'm saying that
probably the energy of the universe is
not constant the energy of the universe
is increasing
and that energy of the universe
increasing is because of time and that's
what dark energy is
the mismatch and dark energy in the
universe is not dark energy it's just
evidence of time
i think go into that for me
so there are two things in the universe
we don't understand there's dark matter
what that means if you look at all the
galaxies right now and you calculate the
um you look at the size of the galaxy
and the rotation and the fact there's a
compact mass
if you do calculations with gravity
so you do calculations of that
observable mass and you look at the
structure of the galaxy the galaxy
should not be holding together it should
be flying apart so some of the mass is
missing so the physicists said well we
can't see it let's just call it dark
matter and there's stuff in there i
think that's okay that could be a hint
there's something wrong with gravity but
i think most physicists are
of the uh are fairly comfortable the
fact that there's some non-luminescent
stuff that's in the galaxy called dark
matter
gravity attracts together galaxy is
lovely fine so that's dark matter let's
not worry about that
but there's this other thing called dark
energy that we need to somehow
understand the rate of expansion of the
universe and to balance things out
and we just don't know what that is
where it comes from my wild idea is that
the amount of dark energy in the
universe was zero at t equals zero
because there was no time
and as the universe increases the energy
expands in time the energy of the
universe increases because of the energy
associated with space
and because time came first and produce
space
the energy associated with space is just
inflating
so it's almost like the singularity at
the beginning is pulling energy from
non-space which seems really weird but
that is really weird and inflating into
space
and we're actually measuring that
evidence of that is is dark energy
how do the physicists feel about this
idea
um they just don't talk to me about that
they they just ignore it i think because
they
they are for some reason
time ha is an emerge they have to
well
think what they feel about it they just
think i'm talking complete nonsense
truth be told some physicists who think
that there's the but they're well no
actually not entirely let's be fair
they are confused because i'm unable to
give a precisely
defendable
theory around that
but what i say is like well
for the universe to have an origin
what we have right now the universe must
have had lots of order at the beginning
everyone agrees this entropy that we got
you know this order at the beginning is
allowing us to run down the clock of the
universe so if the physicists are right
and entropy is expanding excreasing with
the universe that we something put that
order there at the beginning
and that means the initial conditions of
the universe were set that means what
happens to the universe actually
is pre controlled by the initial
conditions
that you're all the questions you're
going to ask me today were not decided
by you in the last few hours
or by you doing some research but but
the universe at the beginning so you
know the the first photon that came into
existence and then under broke symmetry
breaking so that all happened that's
clearly nonsense
and
um and the reason why that's clearly
nonsense is there's not there wasn't the
information capability in the universe
there
so that means there's something wrong
when you're saying the initial
conditions
prescribe all the future because they
couldn't barely they could barely
prescribe the next moment
so
actually the physicists are in a trap
in the um
the origin of the universe requires
order
and if you give that and you can get
right to second law time is emergent
causation is emergent
but you have to predict this order from
somewhere so and then you have to make
these four beliefs
um
so order at the beginning
time is immersion
causation is immersion
second law if i just say there's time
and and it's asymmetric you don't need
those four beliefs because
the second law is obvious you don't need
it you don't need order to be in the
past because there's just time going
forward there's always going to be more
disorder or a larger space from which to
spread out your your your matter in the
future so all that breaks down
but that requires the physicist has to
give up the initial conditions
and that's really hard
i can't imagine why they don't want to
play with you given the fact that you're
curling one out in the middle of their
lovely very well established set of
rules and procedures that everything's
been based upon
well i mean i do think that their
the standard model and the newtonian
dynamics we've got and the einsteinian
dynamics are pretty damn good
pretty damn good planes trains
automobiles go to the moon making
transistors so physicists have got
strong
you know it works
however it doesn't predict life and
novelty and creativity and the fact that
we realize there's something wrong with
our universe is the fact that human
beings are able to be creative and
almost think beyond the edge of the
universe
when you have a creative thought that
thought is almost existing
beyond the edge of the known and then
you can take that from thoughts
and actualize it in the known universe
you're going to be saying you're going
to come up against physical real
restrictions you can think things that
you can't do
sure but you could also think things you
can then have a material impact in the
universe that unless you thought of them
they wouldn't have happened so spacex
elon musk deciding to land a rocket on
legs someone invented that in their head
and they allow now rockets land on legs
i have in my uh twitter bio locally
reversing entropy
as a
little tagline it's been there for ages
i heard it in a podcast years ago
and um
that it kind of is one of those is that
is that an accurate statement to say
that human beings and life does locally
reverse entropy
yes i think it's more than that i think
what you're what that is a marker that's
a
a
very nice way of saying gently
um
that the
causation
and memory in the universe is a thing
and
what what you're able to do by locally
so the thing let's think about the
thought experiment so what you can do
when people think about reversibility
and you say right we're going to do an
experiment let's let's imagine
um a universe about time but hang on you
have to stop
it requires time to do that it's kind of
insane that the to to have to imagine
the time where there is no time you have
to stop and time goes by it's kind of
insane and it's almost like saying right
let's imagine the universe in which all
the prime numbers are available okay
tell me the all the prime numbers
available but you don't need that you
need a resource called time to actually
mine the prime numbers so the existence
of ever increasing prime numbers is
evidence that time exists i think i
can't steal money from your bank account
well not that i would try but let's say
i will just uh by breaking your
encryption key is evidence that time
exists
so because physicists will all be rich
otherwise so this locally reversing
entropy is a bit a bit about saying well
we need to do work on our environment by
doing work we can position objects where
we want them to be which fights disorder
we set the initial conditions we can
make objects and so on and that's kind
of
the way that i started to build assembly
theory um which is from controlling
those initial conditions and causation
and i just think that you know
i think that entropy hasn't really done
very much for us
it should have done
i like that idea okay so going back to
what you touched on earlier on about the
origins of life you have an inkling
you're the first guy at the party
is it
tar and primitive sugars or what's going
on what do you think um so going to the
origin of life i think that's a really
important question i think it goes
beyond that what i'm trying to do in my
lab not just in my lab with
collaborators in in the us and and
germany and and all around the world
lots of people coming to the by at the
same time but there's a physicist i'm
working with with asu who's we're kind
of on the same page there
um and what we think is happening
is that selection the process of
selection making memories can occur
before biology in life and selection
occurs in stuff where there's where
there's just any physical stuff
selection can start
and so what that allows us to understand
is that selection in matter
predates biology by a long way
and that starts to weave those memories
and over time molecular machines get
built and those molecular machines are
recruited by the available chemistry you
have on earth so the origin of life is
about inventing selection i think and
selection comes before biology
and that's what our inkling is
and so on earth
that leads to carbon-based life but i
think elsewhere there's going to be
loads of other possibilities so i think
that we want to understand how selection
predates evolution and i think that
we've come up with we understand it's
almost like a new force in the universe
that selection drives complexification
such to the point where
systems can be this is a i don't like
this phrase but i'll use it anyway
becomes self-governing self-referencing
and when an object cares about its own
existence in time
it's on the way to life
because you have a number of ways
existing if you're a rock you just sit
there and do nothing and you're caught
made of hard stuff but if you're sand
you'll get blown away and broken up all
the time and the fact that we exist
you know the meaning of life is like
existence literally just one word
existence through adversity
because you're because there's
weathering and so on selection allows
you to build repair mechanisms so
what we're doing in the lab is we're
building experiments from the inorganic
world that go select go and undergo
selection
in this case they work with organic
molecules and they start to produce
molecules that will turn into a kind of
biology
but i'm pretty sure the biology we have
on earth the life we have on earth is
unique to earth there is no other
biology in the entire universe and if we
i mean by biology i mean proteins and
dna and the specific
nature of the stuff but life is
everywhere and i think that life is
likely to be as common as you know stars
and hang on so
life on earth is completely unique
but life in the universe is
widespread
yes so
the your view it seems is
we have a very myopic understanding of
what life consists of because we're only
looking at carbon-based
this particular atmosphere has to
respirate has to
do the sex thing to make more of itself
and replicate and stuff like that
and
your view is much broader than that that
there are essentially as many ways to
create life
as there are potentially planets to have
life on
yeah and i think there will be
commonalities like in stars just um i'd
like uh if you take our star at the
center of our solar system if you just
like if we just pretended we couldn't
see any other stars in the sky there was
just one star we would probably look up
in the sky and look at the star and
obsess about how did it form
what were the conditions that made it
and all that stuff and obsessed obsessed
obsessed now the shroud has been taken
taken and we can classify stars
everywhere you know by the luminosity
and the size and so on and their
spectrum that we know that basically
there's a whole statistical distribution
of stars in which our sun is one of
those and i wonder when we if we could i
don't know if we ever will be able to
survey life in the universe that will
see life like that and then it's kind of
cool to think about that because what i
would like to do is convince nasa and uh
issa saying well look with telescopes so
jwst
we should try and look for survey stars
and planets and try and look for planets
that may be of us rocky planet similar
conditions similar mass why because we
know that life like us
that works on the second to hour-to-day
time scale exists there and that's my
why we might be our best chance of
identifying aliens because probably life
can exist anywhere but is the time scale
right for us to talk to is the chemistry
right for us to recognize you know
there's so many variables so contingent
that it's going to be really hard to
understand
what are some of the commonalities that
you're going to see between all life
between most life should i say i would
guess and this is just guess because
we've just got life on earth that
evolution will be common because
selection and evolution go together so
you'll have an entire ecosystem where
there'll be lots of life form different
life forms sharing common
machinery so that'd be one thing i would
think that probably the ability to have
some kind of
computing not computing devices some
kind of information processing device
some sensors
maybe depending on them on the mass of
the planet imagine you know could
imagine if um
life started on a planet where the
gravity was less
strong
we might not have needed to wait so long
to get to multicellular life form
because one of the reasons why it took
so long is we needed to develop
oxygen metabolism oxygen metabolism took
ages to develop why did we need that
because of the gravity
yeah because of gravity was strong
oxygen gives you more energy just really
super boost just fighting against earth
yeah so if gravity gravitational
strength was less maybe so maybe gla
maybe earth is at the bottom of the
class in iq because it took so long to
get intelligent
and on a
planet that didn't have as much gravity
the
organisms would be able to grow more
quickly which means that they would be
able to become more sophisticated more
quickly and they'd be able to develop
and
become a type 3 civilization okay that's
interesting
what
about other exotic forms of life so i i
watch a a channel called melody sheep
i'm not sure if you've ever heard of it
dude you would adore this youtube
channel so these guys make uh
documentaries on youtube about one every
year to year and a half and they're
usually between 30 and 60 minutes long
the whole thing's beautifully
soundscaped and rendered in 3d it's
unbelievably it looks like it should be
on netflix and they've done i think a
three-part or a four-part series which
is um
looking at different ways that life
could have evolved on other planets what
would have happened if it was very high
gravity what would have happened if the
atmosphere was unbelievably more dense
and you can have these creatures that
are kind of like whales but they surf
through the air
and then they moved on to some what they
called very exotic types of alien life
and one of the ones that they mentioned
which is why i brought up with the sand
earlier on is silicon based life and
they said that if you had silicon based
life metabolisms could be so slow that
thoughts might take millions of years
and this is my only
tangential
bit of consumption apart from your work
that i've had into this world so can we
have silicon life what other exotic
types of life are there and can thoughts
take a million years
well i think a thought can take as long
as it needs as long as the environment
doesn't change such that you break
registry
so
millions of years i don't know i i'm
going to watch this youtube channel
thanks for tuning in i think you'll
absolutely love it man it's so good i
think
i think that you thoughts could take
let's say days
because i think you know silicon is
imagine silicon might be faster because
silicon can move electrons around you
know we might have diamond brain there
might be aliens with diamond brains
right so diet or graphene brains because
of what you can have is you can have car
highly ordered carbon and have these
networks and if you don't the networks
it might be such that you can just
basically say here's a big diamond we'll
use that as an information storage
medium and wherever we break we have
dangling bonds and diamonds or defects
that can be you know i'm just making
stuff up so the problem that we have
imagining silicon life is that silicon
requires high pressure high temperature
all this stuff to happen um
but i i don't know what the the life
that this the lifespan would be if
you're talking about millions of years
let's we could do the math humanity's
been around for a few hundred thousand
years thinking and so if we and the
universe has been here for about 13.7
billion years so it's
you know 1 300 1 370 million years
so probably not because we won't have
had many thoughts since the beginning of
the universe yes i understand okay what
other exotic forms of life have you
considered that there might be out there
oh i think silicon is a good one i think
on venus we might have complex chemistry
games there i think that there might be
different forms of life on titan and
europa on based on carbon but completely
different weird stuff because it's
liquid alkanes very cold so you're so
the type of chemistry you've got
available is not going to be as rich as
you have on earth because you won't have
the you know the set of compounds but
really
um the periodic table is pretty big
but what i think you're going to see is
that when stars form
they undergo few the under we know that
stars go for a fairly normal kind of
life cycle so they undergo fission they
keep building up elements and complexity
so more and more heavier and then the
star explodes then that material creates
and then what happens is the heavier
stuff goes to the center and you get
fractionation so i think that most
planets will present rocky planets will
present with you know iron and nickel
core
lighter elements on the outside so i'm i
think exotic life will be very kind of
exotic but not completely outrageous i
don't know if you know the book by andy
weir the the hail mary yes yeah where he
has that
creature what's it made of what's like
what's it made of so it's made of so
mercury blood but by kind of biological
but kind of inorganic and hot
temperatures quite a cool i like i like
the the result research gone into that
so i'm not sure i could buy the lifeform
would have a mercury blood because
that's really heavy and really like okay
you'd have to have a lot of mercury but
but it is a readily available liquid
right under a large variety of
conditions but i think to be honest with
you
we simply don't know
and i'm a chemist existing on planet
earth one atmosphere
25 degrees celsius liquid water
imagine what a chemist on jupiter would
look like under several million pascals
of pressure where hydrogen
hydrogen is not only a liquid it becomes
a metal and it conducts electrons right
so it's like super interesting so i
would just say no i wouldn't have a bet
on against anything but i would bet that
you would need to be able to measure
the complexity of the object using the
kind of the way i discussed earlier
looking for artifacts and examples of of
non-statistically formed objects that
you could discern from the background
given the fact that you think there's
going to be life not only out there in
the universe but you know in planets
that are next door to us within our own
solar system are you concerned that this
has implications for the great filter
hypothesis robin hansen's thing where he
says that it's an answer to the fermi
paradox there's something big that all
civilizations need to get past if we
find life elsewhere this means that
we've got some huge filter to come up
against
no
[Laughter]
i think there's another big filter
you know what the big filter is
expanding space
and the speed of light oh that you can
get captured in some corner of
well it's hard to get from place to
place i mean okay what's more likely
that we're moving faster from from far
from away from each other to approaching
the speed of light or that we've all i
think that
i think the human human life on earth is
in danger in the end but life on earth
is going to do just
fine i mean why why that why human
lifestyle just wait until skynet comes
it's going to have much more fun it'll
be resilient to the expanding sun you
know
you think we're going to get agide out
of existence
no i think we we won't i mean i'm being
really flippant but we're already become
cyber physical right now you know i'll
have my phone and connected with that
and then we'll have more and more kind
of interactions with technology
and so
um and i'm very hopeful about the future
of life on earth that it won't we should
i mean obviously humans are going to
transition but the race we're in right
now we're in a race to not be idiots
right we're in the base to educate each
other and give everyone a degree of
equity with the with the population and
to try we're trying to get out of this
um
this view
that there are limited resources and
those and we then we need to basically
kind of have certain
people constrained because of those
resources once we really we understand
we're no longer resource constrained for
the technology
the humanity is going to have a field
day it's going to be so fascinating
watching it the latter half of the
century we need to kind of sort out
climate change and sure it's dangerous
and sure crops could fail
but you know what happened if crops fail
and water scarce
a load of people will die
tragedy sure don't i don't want to die
but not everyone will die
and then humanity will go again so you
know i don't think there's a great
filter i think that maybe there's a
great filter on his imagination
oh
dma robin hansen i understand your idea
around the fact that and this is similar
i'm going to get to the ratcheting thing
that you said from earlier on i
understand your idea that technology
opens up capabilities that you can't see
it's like the unknown unknowns of
progression that you can move through
i also think yes
a lot of the problems that we're coming
up against that look like x-risks from
the outside are probably not true
existential risks as in 100 of all
humans are extinguished or that we are
irreversibly put into a situation that
we can't get back from whatever is
irreversible civilizational collapse two
versions of x-risk i don't think i think
you're right there's some maybe you know
the bio-engineered weapons not
tremendously fantastic pretty [ __ ]
robust probably going to do a good bit
of damage but even nuclear war you know
you set off all of the nukes on on the
planet it doesn't kill everybody
it's not nice and it wouldn't be fun for
quite a while but it doesn't kill
everybody so yeah you're right humans
are very very resilient and then you're
so would you class yourself as a
techno-optimist i don't even know what
that really means but i hear people say
on the internet and i feel like i should
use it
um i think that um well i'm trying to
get command of all matter right i'm
trying to create origin of life i'm
trying to
sound like thanos
no because
no no command of all matter oh but i
mean i'm trying to literally program
mata digitally so i want to get digital
control of mata to basically build stuff
and i just need information and energy
for that so there's enough energy coming
from the sun for me to transform all the
matter on earth over time in fact
biology's been doing it arguably so i am
an optimist and i think that we should
enable people to have a growth mindset
we've got political difficulties and so
on there's all sorts of interesting
things like humanity is coming we're in
we understand what economics is we
understand what creativity is we're
understanding that we are pretty
interesting in a causal chain that we're
worth preserving and i think that this
kind of we're also understanding that
our culture
communicates some very deep and
important truths about our past into the
future that we don't know yet how to
write down
you know we are recording some of it and
we're capturing even if it's like in the
manifestation of youtube and tick tock
so yeah i would say i'm a techno
optimist um
not just because i'm living in some
bubble somewhere because i can see as a
chemist what has chemists done chemists
done last 50 years we've stopped the
population from starving we've
we've decreased infant mortality we have
basically cleaned up the environment yes
and we need to do again and oh dear we
have to remove the plastic and no idea
we have to remove the co2 but we'll do
it again and we'll keep doing that and i
think the
the great filter perhaps the really
great filter is climate change when the
sun expands and engulfs the uh earth but
even then we might have like pushed the
earth back a bit or
evolved into you know i was learning uh
anders sandberg is working on a book at
the moment where he's thinking about
what they call it a galactic landscaping
uh where
precisely that i've got i've got this
lovely view but there's this
planet in the way and if i could just
get that oh lovely or whatever it might
be you know like moving moving an earth
or a habitable planet away from a sun
that's about to expand and destroy it or
whatever it might be
yeah i am
i do
think
moving forward that you're going to see
far more opportunities open up i would
say that technology provides us with a
lot of unknown unknowns that means
the
potential in future is going to be
really really hard for us to grasp
what about
the the chance of
any life in space
is that completely beyond the pale that
something might not need a planet to
exist maybe it could have come from a
planet and now either exists in space or
it could be born in space is that is
that a thing
i don't i don't know i mean my guess
would be that it would probably find
getting a date hard because space is
quite big and gravity is quite useful
to locate you
and and also
um being in a solar system is useful
because you've got access to a reliable
energy source
because you're typically going to be
orbiting a star
there obviously is chance and perhaps a
civilization gets propelled into space
maybe a plant their planet gets ejected
is there an example in the universe
where a planet was happily doing its
stuff and
a good civilizations emerged and
suddenly the planet got ejected from the
solar system and they had to quickly
adapt and then they had enough resources
to carry on for a while and it almost
became like a lifeboat and they're
trying to work out how to get captured
by another solar system that could
happen that might be pretty grim
actually the further so just imagine get
phone out your house if you get thrown
out your solar system for bad behavior
that sucks
yeah so i don't know i mean i think the
gravity is useful when energy is useful
um and um our solar system has been a
quite a nice little house backyard for a
while you know we've got the asteroid
belt we've got mars nearby venus nearby
you know we've got obviously the the
planets on the outer solar system which
were the garbage collectors at the
beginning and now stabilized and we've
got this pretty pleasant sun
and so you know i i kind of like where
we are but i'm biased right i guess we
all are you're designed to like where we
are exactly i've evolved to like it yeah
why do you think that
chemistry doesn't seem to have captured
the public's conscience
or consciousness in the same way as
something like physics has you know i
see when i see a chemistry documentary i
go look that's that's look at that
that's chemistry documentary
and then there's swaths and swats and
lots of stuff about space and physics
and even biology right
um so i think because chemistry is hard
in the middle so physics is what's so
wondersome
because it's so simple right
and it's not that simple but there's lit
so it has physics is a low memory affair
so there's not many rules you need to
basically create
the stuff then when you get to chemistry
you have the periodic table and there's
all this information and stuff going so
it's quite piggledy piggledy but then
when you get to biology although it's
messy you now have cells you have
variation and you can see the genome so
i think the chemistry is kind of trapped
between the simplicity of physics and
the
just splendor of biology
and um we're we're too busy you know
curing cancer and and getting the work
done get getting the work yeah i should
say that
shots fight okay so talk to me about you
mentioned earlier on uh viruses and you
made an analogy between a human not
being on earth versus a virus being
basically outside of what i'm guessing
would be a host
have you considered whether
is it likely that stuff like that would
also be on other planets other types of
life would it be typical to see
parasites and viruses and other things
like that
i think so i mean and i also think that
perhaps the origin of life was a virus
origin of life and that things would get
together in the dance for so long and
that would maximize the ability to
explore the solutions and then cells
were a relatively late
comer to the machinery and the cells
were just like kept stuff together it's
like right i'll have you i'll have you
have you stay together please replicate
together run chance happenings and i
think there is reason to believe that
selection will occur
at that kind of level or in the over the
universe and i would wonder if viruses
are a universal characteristic of life
but wouldn't it be fascinating if we go
to titan or indeed we find viruses
coming from the outer solar system that
have completely different
technology or evolved technology that we
can see it's complicated we can see it's
biological ish but we don't recognize
the base pairs in the dna and we don't
recognize the protein
that would be that would be mind-blowing
i read a blog post a while ago talking
about how a lot it was a potential
answer to the fermi paradox talking
about how a lot of life may evolve
underwater there's a lot of water out
there liquid water one of the problems
you have with liquid water is that
becoming an advanced civilization is
pretty difficult because you can't smelt
[ __ ] you're not smelting anything and
you're not flying anywhere on an
ice ship uh is that something else that
you've considered about the way that
life that's exclusively under water
could perhaps develop
probably i mean it might not have any
version but i think the fermi paradoxes
is not a paradox it's just because
fermi's imagination wasn't big enough
and i just think the problem yeah i mean
you know but so everyone is saying
coming up with reasons why that stuff
doesn't happen on the data point of one
i know so i i'm pretty sure there's life
everywhere in the universe but it's a
um a continuum so you start from almost
non-life sand you go up up up up up
selection selection selection section
kind of autonomic some autonomy at the
cellular level multicellularity cr
animals intelligence
rockets and i think that we are
basically characterizing it all wrong we
shouldn't be looking for an on off
switch we'd be saying oh there's more
memory there than not so there's
probably the process that gives life
everywhere
but can we go and talk to someone well
and i think the thing that reason fermi
didn't understand is that and is that
the
causal chain of events
the fact that we can talk to each other
and everyone on planet earth can kind of
understand the culture is that we shared
a common ancestor and that you know from
mathematics to singing to whatever you
know we might we find an alien we might
not actually know it's an alien we might
not even
understand we're seeing it the fermi
paradox might just be a
a a a
basically a polarizing filter on your
eyes and you just can't see the evidence
of life which is why we have to build a
new detection system to look for
complexity first and then ask us and
then put it on the scale and that's one
of the things i'm doing because then i
can build a machine to make complexity
and say how complex is it and how much
did i cheat because i'm cheating in my
lab right everyone says you know i mean
i'm my joke is like i don't want i'm not
a creationist i don't sorry i don't
believe i'm not a creationist but i want
to be one
which is basically i don't believe in a
creationist god but if i make the
chrononites
they are going to worship me i'm going
to make sure of it fantastic i love it
look lee cronin ladies and gentlemen lee
if people want to keep up to date with
the work that you're doing and your lab
and all that stuff where should they go
so uh my twitter at lee cronin um also
my webpage um croninlab.com
and yeah just so just use that google
thing
lee i appreciate you thanks mate what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]